Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter One, the final episode, Episode Six: Denmark in the global community, from 1990 to today.
Danish history since 1990 has stood under the sign of globalisation.
The Berlin Wall and the Iron Curtain fell, and new conflicts broke out.
The fight against terrorism has also marked the world and Denmark, and Denmark has played a new and more active role in international affairs.
The EF expanded its political cooperation and was renamed the European Union, the EU, but Danes embraced the new EU only hesitantly.
The country's economic situation, though interrupted by a financial crisis in 2008, improved again, and problems integrating refugees and immigrants into society occupied more and more people.
And in 2020, a global health crisis hit with Covid-19.
Let's start with the fall of a system.
Around 1990, the communist system in Eastern Europe collapsed.
The fall of the Berlin Wall in 1989, in November, and the dissolution of the Soviet Union in 1991, meant the end of the Cold War.
It brought big changes in Europe.
Central and Eastern European countries that had earlier lain behind the Iron Curtain now moved politically closer to Western Europe.
Denmark got close ties especially to the three Baltic countries: Estonia, Latvia and Lithuania.
After the Cold War, new conflicts broke out, among others in Iraq and in the former Yugoslavia.
From now on Denmark took part more actively in international conflicts and became involved in several of these wars.
After Iraq had occupied Kuwait in 1990, Denmark sent a warship to help enforce the international community's trade blockade against Iraq.
Yugoslavia was dissolved in 1991 to 92.
In its place arose a number of independent states, which quickly came into conflict with each other.
Danish soldiers were stationed as UN forces, in Bosnia and Croatia, in the middle of the 1990s.
They were to help create peace between the parties to the conflict.
Kosovo, which at that time was a province in Yugoslavia, was also hit by conflict in 1999.
Here Danish fighter planes took part in NATO's actions.
Now, Denmark and Europe.
Denmark's relationship with European cooperation was marked by political disagreement in the 1990s.
In 1992, the twelve member countries agreed to expand the cooperation, and the EF changed its name to the EU, the European Union.
The name change reflected that the cooperation, which until then had been cooperation on economic questions such as trade, agriculture and fisheries, was expanded with a broader range of political areas of cooperation.
A majority in the Folketing was in favour of Denmark taking part in the expanded cooperation.
But according to the constitution, it was necessary to hold a referendum.
In June 1992, a small majority of the population, fifty point seven percent, voted no to the Maastricht Treaty, as the union agreement came to be called, because it was concluded in the town of Maastricht in the Netherlands.
In 1993, a majority of the population, fifty-six point seven percent, voted yes to the so-called Edinburgh Agreement, which meant that Denmark got four so-called opt-outs, forbehold, from the EU.
That means that Denmark did not take part in the EU's cooperation in the following four areas: Union citizenship, the common currency (the euro), the defence area, and the cooperation on a common justice and immigration policy.
Only two of the four opt-outs still apply today: the euro, and justice and immigration.
Therefore Denmark, for example, still has its own national currency, the krone, whereas most EU countries have the common currency, the euro.
And Denmark also does not take part in the EU's common justice and immigration policy.
The opposition to the EU in parts of the population also became one of the reasons why the Red-Green Alliance, Enhedslisten, which in 1989 had been formed as a coming together of a number of smaller left-wing parties, was elected to the Folketing for the first time in 1994.
Despite the EU opt-outs, a clear majority of the Danish population is positive towards Danish membership of the EU.
Then, the economy turned.
In 1993, the Social Democrats came to power again, with Poul Nyrup Rasmussen as the new prime minister.
The economic problems Denmark experienced in the 1970s and 1980s turned into an economic upturn.
In the middle of the 1990s, economic growth rose again, and more people got jobs.
In addition, the production of oil and gas from the Danish fields in the North Sea meant that Denmark gradually got a net export of oil.
That contributed to the surplus on the trade balance getting bigger, and the debt to other countries gradually being paid off.
The debate on immigration to Denmark took up more and more space during the 1990s.
The number of persons with an immigrant background had risen a lot in the preceding decades, and in the bigger Danish towns, districts had emerged where many residents had an ethnic background other than Danish.
At the same time, many refugees and immigrants found it difficult to get education and work.
The question of integration got great political attention in this period, among other things because relatively many people with a foreign background in Denmark did poorly in the education system, and because a relatively large share was without work and received social benefits such as cash benefit, kontanthjælp, and early retirement pension, førtidspension.
Many Danes also thought that some immigrants had a culture that was very different from the Danes', and that they were not always good enough at learning the Danish language.
The wish for tightening of the foreigners and integration policy among many Danes was of great importance for the Danish People's Party, Dansk Folkeparti, with party founder and party leader Pia Kjærsgaard, born 1947, at the head, being elected to the Folketing for the first time in 1998.
Pia Kjærsgaard led the party from 1995 to 2012, and from 2015 to 2019 she was the first woman to be Speaker of the Folketing.
The Danish People's Party contributed to the foreigners policy becoming an important theme at the general elections in the following decades.
Other political parties, however, also gradually took up the subject.
Poul Nyrup Rasmussen was prime minister from 1993 to 2001.
In 2001, the centre-right parties regained government power.
The prime minister became Anders Fogh Rasmussen from Venstre, prime minister from 2001 to 2009.
Discussions about foreigners and integration continued, and the new government carried through several tightenings of the foreigners policy.
The aim was to limit parts of immigration, get more people into work and improve integration.
Some of the following governments have carried through further tightenings of the foreigners policy.
For example, a requirement has been introduced that you must have stayed for a longer period in Denmark and have worked before you can receive full cash benefit.
In addition, foreigners must have lived longer in Denmark to get Danish citizenship, the indfødsret, just as they must meet requirements for work and self-support.
Further, you must not commit serious crime, and you must pass a series of tests in the Danish language and in Danish history, society, culture and values.
That, of course, is the very test you are preparing for.
It has also become harder to bring a spouse from abroad to Denmark.
Among other things, both persons must be at least twenty-four years old, the so-called twenty-four-year rule, and meet a series of requirements regarding, among other things, work, self-support, education, housing and Danish language skills.
The aim is to secure the best possible starting point for successful integration of the spouse who comes to Denmark.
But not everyone has agreed on the stricter foreigners policy.
Opponents have criticised, among other things, that the lower financial benefits create increased poverty, and that the stricter requirements for family reunification split families, and have made it too difficult, also for Danish citizens, to get a spouse into the country.
Now to terror and conflict.
The international community changed rapidly at the beginning of the new millennium.
The global economy and international terrorism confronted Denmark with new challenges.
After the terror attack on the USA on the eleventh of September, 2001, combating terrorism became an important task in most countries.
This has especially led to increased cooperation between intelligence services, but also to military interventions, in which Denmark has taken an active part.
Behind the attack on the USA in 2001 were terrorists who operated from Afghanistan, in understanding with the then Afghan regime.
In 2002 the Folketing decided to send Danish soldiers to Afghanistan to take part in an American-led effort.
In 2003 the USA attacked Iraq to remove the Iraqi dictator Saddam Hussein and Iraq's alleged weapons of mass destruction.
Again, the Danish government backed it and sent Danish soldiers.
One of Denmark's biggest foreign policy crises in recent times developed after the newspaper Jyllands-Posten in 2005 printed twelve caricature drawings of the Muslim prophet Muhammad.
The newspaper printed the drawings because it had heard that some illustrators did not dare to draw Muhammad for fear of being attacked or killed.
The caricature drawings led to big protests both in Denmark and abroad.
In many Muslim countries there were big demonstrations, where, among other things, the Dannebrog was set on fire, and in a few places, in Syria and Lebanon, also Danish embassies and consulates.
A number of countries also boycotted Danish products because of the drawings.
Jyllands-Posten was in 2008 acquitted in a defamation case brought by a number of Muslim organisations.
The debate about freedom of expression did not end there, however.
In 2010, an attempt was made to murder one of the illustrators in his home.
In 2015, Denmark was hit by a terror attack in Copenhagen, where a man who sympathised with the terror organisation Islamic State shot and killed a film-maker while he took part in a debate meeting about "Art, blasphemy and freedom of expression" at Østerbro.
Later the same day, the terrorist tried to force his way into the Jewish synagogue in central Copenhagen.
In the attack, a Jewish guard was shot and killed outside the synagogue.
The terrorist was afterwards himself killed in an exchange of fire with the police.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Which party was Poul Nyrup Rasmussen chairman of when he was prime minister, from 1993 to 2001?
Option A: The Conservative People's Party.
Option B: Venstre.
Option C: The Social Democrats.
[DA] Hvilket parti var Poul Nyrup Rasmussen formand for, da han var statsminister 1993-2001?  A: Det Konservative Folkeparti  |  B: Venstre  |  C: Socialdemokratiet
The answer is C: The Social Democrats.
It appeared in the June 2020 and November 2023 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Socialdemokratiet
Question 2.
When was the Red-Green Alliance, Enhedslisten, first elected to the Folketing?
Option A: 1973.
Option B: 1994.
Option C: 2011.
[DA] Hvornår blev Enhedslisten valgt til Folketinget første gang?  A: 1973  |  B: 1994  |  C: 2011
The answer is B: 1994.
It appeared in the June 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: 1994
Question 3.
Which of the following themes had great political attention in the 1990s?
Option A: Integration of immigrants.
Option B: Denmark's role in the Arctic.
Option C: Danish participation in the war in Afghanistan.
[DA] Hvilket af følgende temaer havde stor politisk opmærksomhed i 1990’erne?  A: Integration af indvandrere  |  B: Danmarks rolle i Arktis  |  C: Dansk deltagelse i krigen i Afghanistan
The answer is A: Integration of immigrants.
It appeared in the June 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Integration af indvandrere
Question 4.
In which year was the Danish People's Party first elected to the Folketing?
Option A: 1958.
Option B: 1978.
Option C: 1998.
[DA] Hvilket år blev Dansk Folkeparti valgt til Folketinget første gang?  A: 1958  |  B: 1978  |  C: 1998
The answer is C: 1998.
It appeared in the November 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: 1998
Question 5.
Which of the following politicians helped found the Danish People's Party?
Option A: Pernille Vermund.
Option B: Inger Støjberg.
Option C: Pia Kjærsgaard.
[DA] Hvilken af følgende politikere var med til at stifte Dansk Folkeparti?  A: Pernille Vermund  |  B: Inger Støjberg  |  C: Pia Kjærsgaard
The answer is C: Pia Kjærsgaard.
It appeared in the November 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Pia Kjærsgaard
Question 6.
When did the Cold War end?
Option A: Around 1950.
Option B: Around 1970.
Option C: Around 1990.
[DA] Hvornår ophørte Den Kolde Krig?  A: Omkring 1950  |  B: Omkring 1970  |  C: Omkring 1990
The answer is C: Around 1990.
It appeared in the June 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Omkring 1990
Question 7.
Which country did Denmark send soldiers to following the terror attack on the USA on the eleventh of September 2001?
Option A: Mali.
Option B: Kosovo.
Option C: Afghanistan.
[DA] Hvilket land sendte Danmark soldater til på baggrund af terrorangrebet i USA den 11. september 2001?  A: Mali  |  B: Kosovo  |  C: Afghanistan
The answer is C: Afghanistan.
It appeared in the November 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Afghanistan
Question 8.
Did the Danish government at the time support the American-led invasion of Iraq in 2003?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Støttede den daværende danske regering den amerikansk ledede invasion af Irak i 2003 (Irak-krigen)?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is A: Yes.
It appeared in the May 2023 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Ja
Question 9.
Which country did Denmark send soldiers to in 2003, following an American-led invasion?
Option A: Syria.
Option B: Iraq.
Option C: Libya.
[DA] Hvilket land sendte Danmark soldater til i 2003 på baggrund af en amerikansk ledet invasion?  A: Syrien  |  B: Irak  |  C: Libyen
The answer is B: Iraq.
It appeared in the May 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Irak
Question 10.
At which place in Copenhagen was a terror attack carried out in 2015?
Option A: At the Jewish synagogue.
Option B: At the Central Station.
Option C: At the airport.
[DA] Hvilket af følgende steder i København blev der begået et terrorangreb i 2015?  A: Ved den jødiske synagoge  |  B: Ved Hovedbanegården  |  C: I lufthavnen
The answer is A: At the Jewish synagogue.
It appeared in the May 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Ved den jødiske synagoge
That's the end of Part One of Episode 6.
In Part Two, we continue with the financial crisis, the welfare state, Covid-19 and today's parties.
See you there.